Another mystery of Star Wars: The Rise of
Skywalker has been solved.
"Sabine — another one coming out!"
Near the film's end, right after the triumph
of Rey over granddad Emperor Palpatine, she
and Kylo Ren appear to exchange words before
the latter vanishes into the Force.
But no dialogue between the two is audible.
As it turns out, they did have some parting
words after all and the movie's novelization
is apparently letting us in on what they had
to say to each other.
You'll recall that Rey, egged on by the voices
of Jedi past in her head, was able to seal
Palpatine's destruction by deflecting his
own hateful, nasty Force lightning back at
him, apparently mortally wounding herself
in the process.
Kylo, however having decided to go ahead and
turn back to the light side and become Ben
Solo again transferred his life force to her
at the last minute.
They had those mysterious words, shared a
chaste kiss, and then he was gone.
"Curious."
According to the novelization, their exchange
wasn't exactly the most creative thing in
the world.
If you happened to take a guess as to what
they might've said, the chances are fairly
good that you were right.
"I couldn't really guess."
The relevant passage in the book reads,
"A voice came to her through the Force, clear
and strong.
'I will always be with you,' Ben said.
She smiled.
Let the truth of it wash over her.
'No one's ever really gone,' she whispered."
"No one's ever really gone."
There you have it, folks; that clears that
right up.
The revelation is a fairly minor one among
the other story-related things that have become
known in the months following Rise of Skywalker's
release.
As is becoming increasingly clear, a whole
lot of seemingly important plot material for
Episode IX just straight-up wasn't in the
movie.
To understand what happened, Disney apparently
would rather you find out in a book sold separately,
of course.
"The sacred Jedi texts!"
The Rise of Skywalker has been accompanied
by a pretty substantial amount of game-changing
supplemental material.
For starters, there's the movie's Visual Dictionary,
released on the same day the film came out;
that ginormous tome revealed such plot points
as the fact that, as many suspected, ex-Stormtrooper
Jannah is Lando Calrissian's long-lost daughter.
"The character you're playing, Jannah, she's
Lando Calrissian's daughter."
"Yeah, there's that rumor."
That book also revealed that the planet Kylo
visits in the film's opening is indeed the
same one Mustafar where Anakin Skywalker lost
his famous game of "The floor is lava" with
Obi-Wan Kenobi, and that the candy apple Sith
Troopers who show up out of nowhere to serve
on his Star Destroyers are actually the children
of Palpatine's worshippers on Exegol.
Oh, and for some reason it also suggests that
the vaunted Knights of the Old Republic RPG
is apparently canon again.
Why not?
"You cannot hide from what you once were,
Revan."
More lost plot points from the movie will
likely be laid out by the five-issue Rise
of Skywalker comic series, to be published
by Marvel Comics starting in May 2020.
And you might recall that even more details
about the movie literally had to be explained
by the movie's crew in various interviews.
For example, the film's editor Maryann Brandon
divulged in a conversation with Huffington
Post why Rey was unable to simply kill Emperor
Palpatine, explaining that she basically can't
strike him down in anger.
Apparently, it's only by reflecting his own
hate back at him or in this case, lightning
bolts that she's able to beat him at his nefarious
schemes.
On another occasion, director J.J. Abrams
himself revealed what it was that Finn kept
trying to tell Rey for the entire movie.
Turns out he wants to tell her that he's Force-sensitive,
and not, like you might imagine, that he secretly
loves her.
"You got a boyfriend?
Boyfriend?"
"It’s None of your business"
Depending on whom you ask, this all makes
Rise of Skywalker either A) a thematically
rich, narratively dense work containing too
much story to fit into its run time; or B)
an incomplete film which asks its fans to
shell out extra cash to fill in its plot holes.
"Yeah, I think you're right."
If you happened to enjoy The Rise of Skywalker
just fine as-is, more power to you.
But either way, we hope the next movie can
manage to fit a whole story in before the
credits roll, and not leave the good stuff
for the books.
The Rise of Skywalker will hit digital platforms
on March 17, and DVD/Blu-ray on March 31.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.